uh gone up and down a certain amount but
has been broadly been flat at a fairly
high level now
uh for uh many weeks and i think people
can slightly over interpret uh slight
down turns and slight upturns uh the
half term effect is making it slightly
more difficult also to interpret the
most recent data but broadly this has
been a flat at a
fairly high level now for a while next
slide please
the number of people in a hospital with
covid
is mercifully a lot lower than it was in
the peak but it is still significant and
again this has been broadly flat for
some weeks now
there's been a slight down turn recently
but it is relatively modest and i think
i should reinforce a point which i'm
sure everyone is aware of that in all
the other areas the nhs is also under
very significant pressure from uh winter
effects and from the catch up from
coveted amongst other things
next slide please
the number of deaths of people who've
had a positive test result for covered
in the uk
also are again broadly flat currently
averaging
around 156
deaths per day
next slide please
i wanted to uh just pause a little bit
on this one this is the number of people
aged 12 and over who receive vaccination
for cover 19 in the uk
and the overwhelming majority of people
have chosen to take up that offer
protecting themselves and those around
them
but i wanted to make two points to those
just backing up what the prime minister
has just said who have not yet come
forward for vaccination
strongly to encourage you to do so the
first is to the general uh population
uh not only will you protect yourself
and you undoubtedly will at every age
you're better off being vaccinated than
being unvaccinated you also protect
those around you and you do so by three
methods
first of all you are less likely to get
covered and obviously if you don't get
it you cannot pass it on
secondly if you do get it you are less
likely to transmit
and the third way is that if you get
severe enough coded to need
hospitalization
and you are unvaccinated
in all probability that is the reason
you're in hospital
and that bed could have been taken by
someone else
so for three reasons i would encourage
people strongly who have not been
vaccinated to do so
i would and the second point i wanted to
make on this like to pull out in
particular
the issue of women who are pregnant
or intending to get pregnant
and i would just like to give you some
fairly stark facts about this because
this is a major concern
based on academic data uh
from the first of february through to
the 30th of september so aiming off
because obviously early on in that
period people of this age would not have
been vaccinated
1714
pregnant women were admitted to hospital
with covid
of those 1681
which is say 98
had not been vaccinated
and if you go to those who are very
severely ill in intensive care of 235
women admitted to icu
232 of them over 98
had not been vaccinated
these are preventable emissions to icu
and there have been deaths
all the medical opinion is really clear
that the benefits of vaccination far
outweigh the risks in every area this is
a universal view among doctors and among
the midwife advisory groups and among
the scientific advisory groups so can i
please encourage all women who are
pregnant or wishing to become pregnant
to get their vaccination and i would
extend that also incidentally to flu
which is also very dangerous for women
who are pregnant next slide please
the number of people who received a
booster or third dose of vaccination is
continuing to rise
as you can see in this graph and as the
prime minister said and
my colleagues professor van tan and
professor lim and dr rain said this
morning jcvi is advised and the
government has agreed uh to extend this
vaccine this booster down the age ground
the range to people in their 40s as well
as uh to advise a second vaccine
for young people uh 16 and 17 18 years
of
age
and just to reinforce the points were
made earlier this morning
there is clear evidence
that having a booster
significantly increases your protection
at all age ranges
and we we would strongly recommend
people who have actually uh been advi
invited to have the booster to do so and
given that we're heading into the very
difficult winter period to do so as soon
as they are eligible to do so
next slide please
the final slide was really just to put
some numbers behind the point that the
prime minister made about the rates of
increase in continental europe at the
moment
and i want to
put a caution
around
comparing absolute rates because the way
different countries measure this is
different so therefore these are not
strictly comparable but the rate of
change because within any country it is
stable the rate of change can be
interpreted and as you can see looking
at there's already been a very
significant increase in eastern europe
which is still ongoing with significant
numbers of people dying in particular
among the unvaccinated but that has now
moved westward and as you can see is now
increasing significantly also in many
western european countries
so we all knew everywhere in europe we
knew that as we went into winter into
the typical respiratory virus flu season
that the risks would be greater and i
think this is a demonstration of the
fact that we're beginning to see a
winter respiratory effect
there will be other reasons as well
so i think it is important that we take
uh kobit con continue to take kovid
extremely seriously and essentially
continue to do the things that have been
consistently recommended vaccination
the boosters including the new areas
but also
ventilation
wearing masters in enclosed spaces
washing hands
and taking sensible precautions as
people have done throughout this
pandemic thank you
thanks chris patrick anything to add
let's go to questions from the public
nigel from hungerford
nigel asks with the current high levels
of infection in school-aged children
what precautions should families take to
avoid exposing older relatives to
infection uh chris why don't i ask you
to to take that one thanks pm i mean i
think that the the biggest and most
important things are obviously uh to um
encourage the older members of the
family to get their vaccination and get
their boosters so that their immune
system is in strong
position and for those children who are
eligible
so that is the great majority of
secondary school children
to uh get their their first vaccination
when it's due and for young people
16 and 17 to get their booster that is
really important but then i think the
sensible precautions that you would
normally expect which include uh
particularly people are vulnerable
considering um
trying to meet people where there's good
ventilation obviously more difficult in
winter but it is a it is practical in
many situations
uh and trying to encourage people to do
sensible things like if they have
symptoms uh not to get too close to
people who are older or vulnerable
including their own family members
thanks very much
uh michael from staffordshire
michael asks inc hello
he's gone here he is again uh
increasingly foreign countries are
demanding proof of booster covered
vaccination for entry to those countries
and to public places why has the uk
government added the booster dose to the
nhs covered travel pass is the booster
dose going to be added uh to the nhs
kobe travel pass and when um
chris patrick i think that we will we
will be making uh plans to add the
booster dose to the uh to the nhs
covered uh travel past but again i think
what the general lesson is uh from
anybody who anybody who wants to travel
uh you you can see that uh getting fully
vaccinated uh with a booster is going to
be something that will on the whole make
your life easier in all kinds of ways
including uh for foreign travel so i
would i would just say you know if
you're thinking about about that this is
yet another reason uh to get it done but
anything
to add on that
thank you very much let's go to
uh fergus walsh bbc news
thank you prime minister can you
categorically rule out
a christmas lockdown and how dependent
is that on booster jabs thanks ferguson
everybody has been asking this for her
for some time now and all i can do is is
humbly repeat the
the mantra that we don't see anything in
the in the current data that leads us to
think that we need to go to to plan b uh
which is as you know uh
several steps short of a of a lockdown
but nonetheless would require more
restrictions we don't see any uh any
anything in the data that says we have
to go now to to plan b
um but
clearly we cannot rule
anything out and the most important
thing people can do to prevent further
uh mpis from being taken is to
non-pharmaceutical interventions that is
um
further restrictions
get the boosters you know it's going
well the numbers are climbing 12.6
million is a huge number to to have hit
the gps are hitting it out of the park
again they're doing an amazing job
and they're getting loads of jabs into
into loads of arms i went out 75 percent
for uh the over 70s uh more for uh for
the for the over uh 75 to 79 groups and
for the over 80s it's it's starting to
build a lot of momentum but we need to
see those 50-plus groups and the 60-plus
groups who can also wind up in hospital
very very easily uh getting their
booster as soon as as soon as you're
called forward to get it that's the best
protection uh we can have
um
but you know to repeat i see nothing in
the data at the moment that makes me
think we have to go to to further
measures uh emily morgan of itv
thank you very much um the jcbi admitted
to me earlier that there's still a
really long way to go to encourage just
eligible over 50s to have their booster
are you really confident that uptake in
the over 40s is going to be any higher
than the over 50s and therefore have any
significant impact on
this side of christmas thanks very much
emily well the numbers are climbing and
it's it's good it's good to see the way
people are
so i think in over uh in over 60s when i
would uh maybe 58 over over 50 is 54
uh and uh as people are getting the call
there they're starting to to come
forward uh with with greater speed and
the booking service is now really uh
being very very well used that that's
great to see
um
it is vital the people over 50 come
forward and do it and i i'm sure that
they will that this country really
really pulled together to get the the
first vaccination campaign done it was a
a fantastic effort by
the public in coming forward getting
their jabs and i'm sure that i'm sure
that we can do it again
can i just say i see no evidence it's
leveling off
this is this remains something which
people want to get
and there are long queues for people to
actually get these and that's a good
thing
and you can see that in the numbers of
the older groups that have gone up as
the
campaign has become more effective and
as the convenience i think convenience
is key here to make sure it's easy for
people to book and easy for them to get
it and i think we're going to see an
increased uptake
i think it's the that's right i think
it's the booking in advance uh plus the
the uh
the the
greater number of centers have helped uh
aisha tull from channel four thank you
prime minister uh do you think you've
been too complacent on the roll out of
the booster jabs with the closing of
mass vaccination centers and also a lot
of appointments are being cancelled
that's what people have been told us
should the messaging have been clearer
and stronger from earlier on and just
briefly on belarus and poland do you
agree with the head of the armed forces
that the uk must be ready for war with
russia
um so first of all
on
the the vaccine booster rollout campaign
uh the problem uh if there has been a
problem has really been one of uh of
demand not uh not supply we've been
we've been ready to to distribute the
vaccinations and it's taken some time to
get them uh to get them going uh but the
momentum is now very very much uh with
the campaign and you can see people uh
coming forward we're showing great great
uh public spirit and and the the mood in
the vaccination centers that i visit in
the gp surgeries is is very very
positive and and uh and and optimistic
and and committed on
um
belarus and
uh and uh
and russia
we are sharing solidarity with our with
our friends in uh in poland as as as you
would expect and we would encourage uh
everyone to to work for for peace and
stability in the whole
in the whole uh european region that's
that's the position of the of the uk
government we stand shoulder to shoulder
with our friends
across the whole region uh estonia uh
uh we are there
uh
ben reidy smith from the telegraph
thank you prime minister on
covet one group we're not jabbing right
now are children aged five to eleven
that's deemed safe for you back doing
that and to the scientists
are you advising plan b and if not why
not and just one more topic you have
raised the threat level to severe can
you tell the public anything about the
motivation of what happened in liverpool
and what would be your message to voters
who might be worried right now
um
yeah uh
ben
so on the on the threat level
we're moving from um
uh
substantial to severe on the advice of
of jtac i think that uh that simply
reflects the number of uh of of attacks
that we've seen in the or attacks failed
or successful that we've seen in the
last few weeks and months um but
if as you know
it it
that number
sorry those gradations substantial
severe they they bump around
and um what we're really saying to the
public as a result of what happened in
liverpool is that they've got to be
everybody's got to be vigilant um that's
i think with the message that jtac is is
trying to
uh to get over
and sorry your first question was
yeah so the five to twelves um
here this is something that is being
done in some other european countries
been done in the united states um
we will see what the uh the jcbi has to
say but uh
chris patrick you want to comment on
that i mean just on that i think
you know we haven't yet even got a
license with uh mhra so i think let's
not rush rush our fences on this i think
it'll depend entirely on the data that
are presented to the independent
regulator and the independent scientific
advisory committee uh and on um uh
advice i mean
our advice is to interpret the data as
best we can for ministers and they
obviously make the final decision on
what should be done but if you look at
the data at the moment uh the numbers
are broadly as i said at the beginning
flat
so they're sometimes going slightly down
sometimes slightly up but that's the
number now of course underneath that
there is substantial pressure on the nhs
and that is widely recognized by
everybody ministers obviously included
but in terms of the coveted numbers
they're not currently going up in the
kind of numbers you're seeing in
continental europe but obviously if they
did that would be a situation where
people you know they'll have people to
have to look again at what the situation
was at that stage
thanks very much uh richard vaughan of
the eye
um i have a question which kind of
touches on what michael from
staffordshire said um
will the cobrad rules have to change to
better reflect the fact that people have
boosters and lb clusters fully
vaccinated does that mean you want to
travel as well as
self-isolating domestically if you come
into contact with some of kovic will
that also have to change in the future
in the coming months um
and uh just on rail um new voters
sorry new tory voters in the north will
find out this week that you've
significantly paired back plans for um
new rail links in the in the north um
what's your message to them and why
should they vote tory again
uh thanks very much richard the the
i just want to repeat what i said
earlier on on
boosters it's very clear that getting
three jabs getting your booster will
become an important fact and uh it will
make life easier for you in all sorts of
ways and we will have to adjust our
concept of what constitutes a full
vaccination to take account of that and
i think that is
increasingly obvious the the booster
massively increases your protection it
takes it right back up to over over 90
percent and and as you as we can see
from what's happening uh the two jabs
sadly do start to wane so
we've got to be responsible and we've
got to reflect that uh that fact in the
way we we measure what constitutes a
full vaccination and on the integrated
rail plan
which is going to be absolutely
fantastic
for
the north the north east northwest
midlands
all i can advise you and everybody else
to do uh richard is wait and see when it
is unveiled on i think thursday
david hughes of pa
um prime minister there have been a few
incidents in recent weeks uh cop and on
your visit to hexham general hospital
where you were pictured without a mask
in settings where you might have been
expected to wear one do you accept that
by doing that you are sending a message
that might not be appreciated by the two
gentlemen alongside you on the podium
there
and um for professor witte we've seen a
stark assessment from ambulance trusts
today about the situation that they're
facing we know the nhs is under pressure
yourself and mentioned it it's only
mid-november with a long winter ahead
how resilient is the nhs to even a small
increase in the number of uh coveted
hospitalizations
uh yeah so so
david first of all i wear a mask
wherever the rules uh say that i should
and i urge everybody else to do the same
and people will actually have
seen me wearing face coverings uh
quite a bit more regularly recently as
as we've seen the
the numbers uh ticking up in in the uk i
think that's the responsible thing to do
and i'm going to going to continue to do
it but what we're also going to do is
we're going to continue with our
approach uh which is uh to rely on
people's common sense uh to on people's
sense of personal responsibility to
themselves and to others but clearly uh
in confined spaces where you're meeting
people that you don't normally meet you
should wear a face covering and that's
that's the that's the advice we're
giving
on the second i'm afraid the answer is
that you you can't give a sort of
uh you know simple answer the answer is
lots of different bits of the nhs are
under different levels of pressure some
of them much less so
but some of them are significant
pressure and clearly we haven't yet got
to the point where the flu season would
typically start that's usually towards
mid or end of december so i think we've
got a difficult winter ahead of us as
professor van tam said this morning i
think that's a widely uh accepted
situation
the nhs is is a remarkably resilient
organization
nevertheless everybody would accept that
large parts of it particularly at the
moment the ambulance system but there
are others uh a e and others
are under very significant pressure and
i'm afraid likely to remain so over the
winter period which is why all health
staff would reiterate the point that pm
has made about encouraging people to get
vaccination that's the single simplest
thing people can do to help reduce
pressure over the rest of the winter
period
great thank you all very much thank you
thank you thank you thank you i've got
to go and give a statement see you
so
this is the ife circuit for sky news
london
this is the i
protection as perhaps it did when you
first got it because it wanes you will
need a booster in fact the prime
minister indicated there and the answer
to the penultimate question he was asked
about boosters and travel he said we may
need to adjust what our idea of being
fully vaccinated is essentially saying
that you're not fully vaccinated unless
you've had the booster now at the moment
it's very difficult to say